who are the best governors in the
country we don't really need to guess
just ask yourself where are people
moving are they moving to michigan
are they moving to new york are they
moving to california all great states
but run by total incompetence political
hacks
corrupt people no they're moving to
florida actually people want to live a
free american life for moving to florida
ron desantis is the governor of florida
and if you're the democratic party or
it's minions in the media there's a huge
problem because the guy's succeeding
clearly that's why people are moving to
a state so you better crush him before
he gets elected to something else
last night cbs did its best 60 minutes
report that ron desantis is bad because
he authorized the supermarket chain
publix to distribute the corona vaccine
in florida
and he did that for one reason publix
donated money
to ron desantis is that real
well no first the head of florida's
emergency management department who's a
democrat tweeted that his division not
the governor's office had recommended
publix
okay so it's clearly not true then it
emerges 60 minutes
deceptively edited their reporters
exchange with ron desantis
here's what they aired on the show
publix as you know donated a hundred
thousand dollars to your campaign
and then you rewarded them with the
exclusive rights to distribute the
vaccination in palm beach well that's
what you're saying is wrong
how is that not paid that's a fake
narrative i met with the county mayor i
met with the administrator i met with
all the folks at palm beach county and i
said
here's some of the options we can do
more drive-through sites we can give
more to hospitals
we can do the publix and they said we
think that would be the easiest thing
for our residents
but melissa mckinlay the county
commissioner in the glades told us
the governor never met with her about
the public's deal
the criticism is that it's pay to play
governor it's wrong it's a fake
narrative
i just disabused you of the narrative
and you don't care about the facts
so that's the woman cbs sent down to
stop ron desantis before he gets bigger
and that's what they aired on the show
here's the full tape
as we got into january we wanted to
expand the distribution points
so yes you had the counties you had some
drive-through sites you had hospitals
that were doing a lot
but we wanted to get it into communities
more so we reached out to other retail
pharmacies publix walmart
obviously cvs and walgreens had to
finish that mission and we said we're
going to we're going to use you as soon
as you're done with that
for the publix they were the first one
to raise their hands say they were ready
to go
and you know what we did it on a trial
basis i had three counties i actually
showed up that weekend and talked to
seniors across four different publics
how was the experience is this good
should you think this is the way to go
and it was a hundred percent positive
it's funny you didn't see any of that in
60 minutes apparently they ran out of
minutes
we don't spend a lot of time defending
politicians on the show normally we
attack them and enjoy it
but this was such an obvious hit such a
transparent political move that we just
couldn't resist we wanted to talk to the
governor himself ron desantis
governor of florida joins us tonight
governor thanks so much for coming on
it's kind of hard to imagine i was just
thinking the other day all these people
moving to florida they're probably going
to try and take out desantis pretty soon
it didn't take them long did it
well not only that tucker but lost in
this is we
vaccinated now three and a half million
senior citizens we were the first state
to say we're doing seniors first
we're not going to follow the cdc's
recommendation and what we have done has
worked and they didn't want to discuss
that and obviously they selectively
edited
the background they tried to act like
there was a conspiracy with publix
ignoring the fact that other pharmacies
were involved before publix
doing all our long-term care facilities
and ignoring the fact that i met with
the county mayor
who's now as a democrat who said what
what 60 minutes has done his bunk
but palm beach calculated 90 percent of
their seniors live within a mile and a
half of a publix
so when we put it in there their numbers
started going through the roof so it
succeeded there but
what they didn't tell you also tucker is
when there was a need in a more rural
part of the county
like near lake okeechobee we set up a
separate site in a small town called
pahokee they didn't tell you that
they didn't tell you that we were doing
african-american church
vaccination drives before publix ever
gave a single shot
they didn't tell you that they didn't
tell you that hospitals were doing shots
starting in the third week of december
because it didn't fit the narrative they
don't believe in facts
it was a political narrative it was done
with malicious intent
and a reckless disregard for the truth
they would not talk
to the people who were most relevant to
this because they know those key
democrats jared moskowitz mayor dave
kerner
would blow up their narrative so they
just put their head in the sand
and pretended like those facts didn't
exist
i didn't watch the show because it's sad
to see something as great as 60 minutes
so thoroughly degraded as it has been
but really quick did they mention the
bottom line
number which is the corona death rate
how does florida's death rate compare to
say i don't know new york or california
well new york is one of the top in the
country florida there's 26 states that
are higher than florida per capita
mortality and there's 40 states
that are higher than us for 65 and up
mortality which is that was our focus
and now since we vaccinated so many
seniors we are seeing the
hospitalizations
among seniors plummet so what we did has
worked and obviously they were in
florida for three months 60 minutes
trying to drudge up any dirt that they
could use to smear me
and the best they could come up with is
a baseless conspiracy theory
that was easily debunked not just by me
which they had to edit out
but by two very prominent democrats in
the state of florida
i doubt it will be the last if people
keep coming to your state i have the
feeling that we'll see more 60 minutes
on you and not in a good way ron
desantis governor florida thank you
thanks